so
we're going to hear from water and alan
that's the intro great
yes all right so welcome everyone so
this is the
second tutorial of of the
reinforcement learning theory
semester and this one will be about uh
online learning and bandits
it will be in two parts and i will do
the first part
and enlarge will do the second part
[Music]
all right so let me try to navigate all
these things
okay so what's the purpose of this
tutorial so
first of all we'd like to share with
all the people there are at least 200 of
you
the tools that we need for reinforcement
learning
so we'll build up some of those here and
then we also have some
exploration of surrounding viewpoints
slightly different problems uh slightly
different methods
right and another purpose is maybe to
make sure that we all speak the same
language um
understand each other's perspective sort
of create a shared culture
so i hope that will work let's see
so what's it all about so the the goal
is to
make interactive decision making systems
or sequential decision making systems
that can operate in an unknown
environment
let's see java is completely frozen is
it me or
can everybody else hear me i can hear
you about her
ah okay great so
we're trying to design uh decision
making systems
for unknown environments and we would
like these systems to get
as much reward as possible in a large
variety of environments okay and i'll
make a distinction
that is maybe the main distinction in
this uh line of work
which is what what sort of environments
are we
assuming uh to operate in
so in reinforcement learning i think the
the main
point is that you imagine that your
actions affect
the future state so that makes that you
have to do uh planning
and sort of thinking ahead then in
bandits which is in some sense a simpler
problem
you assume that your action observes
what you see but not what happens
afterward
and then full information online
learning which is this part of the
tutorial is even simpler
you basically think that your actions
really don't affect
anything or maybe they only make
a certain reward for you but there's
observations you observe everything and
the future doesn't care about
what you did right so in that sense it's
a much
restraint problem in some sense
you assume less you need to assume less
to
work in this setting okay so as i said
there will be two parts
the full information part and the
bandwidth part
and for the full information part i want
to talk about two basic problems
namely online convex optimization
and the experts problem then
i would like to go a little bit beyond
the basics and look at two
sort of slightly advanced interesting
extensions
namely follow the regularized leader and
mirror descent
and i want to look at online quadratic
optimization
which is sort of a special problem where
you can have efficient learners
then i would like to illustrate what all
these things are good for
with a couple of applications uh
standard optimization stochastic
optimization
and solving games and then we'll see
some extensions at the very end
okay so let's start with the two basic
problems
okay so maybe one thing to say before we
start
i'm a very pessimistic person this is
the default in
online learning so i'll always talk
about losses and not rewards
but you can just put a minus sign there
if you want
and we're going to think of our
environment
as something that we don't want to make
any assumptions about
so we're basically going to give it uh
some adversary control over all the
environments decisions
all right so let's introduce the first
problem which is online conflicts
optimization
so it's a certain interaction in which
we have to operate
and to simplify things let's say this
interaction will go on for t
many rounds and there is given up front
some convex space let's call it you
indeed engine if you want think of a
ball
uh that we call actions
all right so we'll go interact with the
environment for d many rounds
each round we have to pick an action we
are the learner
so we pick some action wt from our
action space
and then the opponent or the adversary
or the environment
decides how good all the actions that we
have
actually work so to make that sort of
formal we say the adversary picks a
function
that for each action says how good it is
in the form of a loss so that function
we call it ft
so that decides the quality of all the
actions
so that means that our loss at that
point
is ft of wt and we assume and that's the
full information assumption here that
this
function ft is available to us
as we like so we basically know
everything about it
after it's chosen by the environment
okay in some sense it is a bit abstract
there is no predictions there's no
outcomes now nothing it's just
actions and how good they were but when
you're building tools
i think that's a useful thing to have
you don't need to make many assumptions
you can fit many problems in this
framework
okay so that's what we have to do now
let's say
when are we doing a good job so we'd
like to get
small loss and um
it's not really possible to get small
loss but
i guess the next best thing is to say
well
if it was possible to get small loss i
want small loss
so what we're going to do is control
something called the regret
which is the amount of loss that we got
which is the sum of the fdwd
minus the amount of loss that we could
have got
if we had played the best action
for all the rounds
every round so we think of that as the
loss that we could have got
if we know a good action and we look at
how much more loss
we have so that's the regret and that's
the quantity that we're trying to keep
small
so we're designing a learner so that's a
way to pick the wt's
and we will prove that it uh make sure
that the regret is not big
and then we'll look for example at uh is
this learner efficient
because it has to be an algorithm that
we can actually run
[Music]
okay so let's think a bit about how to
build such learners
so if you want to be like the best point
for all the data
then in some sense you are chasing this
best point
you don't know the best point up front
it's only decided at the very end
but you get some information about it
and you're you sort of have to get there
right but if you play at any point
the best point so far then it turns out
you're jumping around
quite a lot in some sense you're
overfitting and that's not a good idea
so the first sort of design principle
that we see
is to say okay let's regularize a little
bit
and there are two ways that you can do
that
you can say well um i should maybe not
play
actions that are quite extreme
so maybe i should penalize those for the
connoisseurs that's the ftrl style of
regularization
and the other thing you can do is you
say well
um maybe i should play iterates
and i should make sure that they don't
move too much
that's the mirror descent style of
regularization
so we will see examples of both and in
some sense
they're not always quite the same but
they're very similar
so we'll just think they are equivalent
okay with that principle in mind let's
look at our first algorithm
it's called online gradient descent
and let's for simplicity assume that the
origin is in our action space u
the algorithm has one parameter which is
a learning rate
we call eta some positive number that we
will set later
and then the algorithm will do the
following so in the first round it has
not seen anything yet
it will play the origin and then it will
update
when it gets to see such a loss function
as follows so it takes the old point
let's see if i point with the mouse hope
you can see it
it takes the old iterate it says
let's compute the gradient of the loss
function
at the point that we played so the
gradient is the direction where things
get higher
so that's where the losses get higher so
we want to get away from that
so we take a step away from the higher
losses
so we go in the direction of smaller
losses with the step size that is
controlled by this learning rate
parameter eta
okay so that's in itself a gradient
descent step
and we have to be a bit careful that we
might go outside of our
action set u so if that happens we
project
back onto u in in
euclidean distance okay so the way that
looks is you have your action space u
you have your iterate wt you update by
taking a
gradient step and if you went outside u
you project back onto you
uh sorry to interrupt there's a question
about the
protocol itself who observes what what
does the adversary know when they're
playing
the functions and what does the player
know when they're playing the points
all right so ambush i'm curious where
you see this question because i thought
this is coming from this chord this this
chord
okay so let me just go back to the
protocol
so the the interaction is happening uh
sequentially d many rounds and basically
i i wrote it explicitly but it's what
every time you meet one of these lines
and some
either the learner or the adversary has
to make a choice
everything that happened before is
observed
okay so if you have to make your
uh iterate your action you know what
happened in terms of
the w's and the f's in all the previous
rounds
and that the f function of the adversary
even knows the wt
so that's completely evil if you want
but it turns out we can deal with that
so there's no information that's hidden
to anyone
okay i hope that helps there
okay so this is the algorithm
let's see what we can prove about it so
here i repeat the algorithm
and we will have to make a few
assumptions so the standard assumption
in this
line of work is to assume boundedness so
we will assume that the domain
the set u is bounded in norm
by constant d and that the gradients are
also bounded
in norm by a constant big g
okay and then we can show that the
regret
which is the difference of our loss
minus the loss of the best point
in hindsight is bounded by
something that scales with d and one
over the learning rate
and something that scales with t and g
and the learning rate itself
okay and then it turns out if you look
at this and optimize the learning rate
you would like to tune it as d over g
square root t
and if you plug that in you get the
classical
gradient descent bound which is that the
regret is at most
d times g times square root t
okay and what this means is that
our regret is sublinear so the overhead
that we are getting
for not knowing this optimal point but
learning it
the overhead is square root d which
means that per round
this overhead is going to zero right so
we're successful at learning
in this task
okay let's have a look at the proof
i just want to go over one or two proofs
in this tutorial just to show you what
they're like
if you don't really catch everything
that's fine the slides will be available
and
the rest of the tutorial will not uh
depend on it
but let's let's look at it a little bit
so the regret was the sum of
our losses minus the sum of this optimal
point in hindsight
and one thing that we can do is we can
say
i know that these functions are convex
so i can bound them by the tangent bound
in the point that we played okay
and then we're going to do some analysis
uh
about well
to somewhat be a mysterious thing but
let's let's look what happens
so we're going to look at let you be
this a good point
at the end so we're going to look how
far is our iterate
from this u in square euclidean norm
okay how what do we know about it well
our iterate is the projection of the
gradient step from the last point
okay good so we're looking at the the
difference between a projected point
and this is a good point you right so
one thing we can do is we can throw away
the projection
and there is a thing called the
pythagorean theorem that says at that
point the distance only becomes larger
so we have the distance of our updated
iterate to u
and then we can work out the quadratic
and write it as the distance from the
previous iterate
minus the cross term plus the
offset all squared
okay and if we reorganize that a little
bit we see that at this point
oops at this point we have the
linearized regret so we can put that to
the left and say the linearized regret
is at most the
the distance of the old iterate minus
the distance of the new iterate
all divided by two eta plus
the square of the gradient times eta
over two
okay so the regret in one round
is bounded by this linear
linearized regret is bounded by this
two terms there is a difference in norms
and there is a gradient term
okay so let's put that in regress
bounded by linearized regress
bounded by sum of gradient differences
and sum of gradient terms sorry norm
differences
and if you look here at these norm
differences you see that they're all
offset by one time index so that means
that they're telescoping
to the first minus the last and we can
even throw away the last because it's a
negative contribution
so we get just the first which is uh
just the normal view because we started
the origin
and this we sum and then we can use the
bounds that we had
on the norm of u and the norm of the
gradients
to have a d squared over two eta plus
eta over
two times dg squared right so that was
the result that we said we wanted to
show
okay so now we proved
for example this bound so we now have a
method based on
gradient descent for operating in this
online conference optimization world and
we have a regret bound that says it's
working
okay so the next step is to ask is it a
good bound
so you can look at it it has three
vectors
scaling with g and d that's completely
natural
they just scale everything including the
regret so
those we believe but maybe the square
root t we should investigate a little
bit
okay so there is a theorem that says
any algorithm that operates in this
online convex optimization protocol
needs to have a regret of order square
root t
so that means you can't really improve
this
so let me just give you a slight uh
flavor of how that works
basically what you're doing is you say
it already works
this lower bound in one dimension so we
can assume that our
our set is some interval say minus one
one
and we can give the losses to be some
linear losses
with coefficients for simplicity that we
make
plus or minus one right so you have your
your you set u and every round the loss
function is either
linear with slope one or linear with
slope minus one
okay so what does that mean well first
of all
your algorithm has expected loss zero
because the coefficients are uh
on average zero good
and the best action is the best action
fit to all the data
so that doesn't have expectable 0
because it's actually random
but you can see that the best action
will either be
on the far left or on the far right and
as a result it will make an absolute
value appear
okay so the expected loss of the best
action is minus the expectation of the
absolute value of the sum of the
coefficients
okay so that's a sum of rather markers
which is
roughly you can think of it as a normal
random variable and the expectation of
such a thing
by for example central limit theorem
type reasoning
is roughly a square root t
so that means that the expected regret
which is the expectation of our loss
minus the expectation of the best is
actually
square root t lower count right and that
means that
it's not only true in expectation but it
has to work for at least one sequence
to be that high
okay
so what did we have so far so we have an
adversarial result
no matter how the loss functions are
chosen
we can learn in this context so that's
super strong
if we think about the proof it sort of
tells us
well we said convex but it's really only
linear is the hard case
so we were analyzing linear things by
linearizing all the time
but we managed to get matching lower
bounds so we completely closed the
problem there
and just as a side note
actually this style of thinking is quite
successful in practice
and if you dig a little bit and look at
what's being done in deep learning which
is driving all the
cool applications of machine learning
and ai these days
they all use at some point optimization
to learn the parameters of the of the
network
and typically that's done with for
example tensorflow
and if you look at the optimizer that's
ada grad
which is the big brother some bells and
whistles added to
online gradient descent okay so the
objective there is not convex but the
methods are successful anyway
oh a question here proof reveals it is
really about linear losses
yes so the um we did a step in the proof
to say
the difference in bosses is upper
bounded by the linearization
and that step is uh tight if the losses
were linear
and it's mostly if in any other case
right so in that sense the linear losses
are the hardest case
for the upper bound and you saw that the
lower bound was also based on linear
losses
and the other question is yes how
arbitrary is arbitrary
uh the the loss functions are arbitrary
they can even be chosen with rw in mind
one way to think about it is that it's
it's it's possible to give the learner
a large loss by just setting the loss of
wt to be very big
but it's not possible to keep on doing
that and not make
all the other actions also bad so if the
opponent wants to give a large possible
burner
it will give a large loss to everyone
and then the difference between the
learner and the best action is still
small
related to that there was a question on
discord as to why the
best in hindsight is a single point and
not a sequence of points
uh let's wait until the extensions
before we answer that
it's a good question we'll get to it
okay so now i want to get to the second
problem which is uh
somewhat related slightly different
it has many names uh for example
decision theoretic online learning
the expert setting or the head setting
prediction with expert advice
all these things mean almost the same
but
slightly different things so i had to
pick one i chose prediction with expert
advice because it's common even though
it's
arguably wrong but okay people started
calling this
this problem that so what's happening
here we have a similar game
of length t rounds but now we say we
have k
many experts okay so what do we do we go
and iterate for t rounds and every round
we choose a distribution so that's again
a wt it's now from the probability
simplex
on k actions right so this is a vector
that sums to
one or non-negative okay
then the opponent says how good are each
of these experts
by revealing a loss vector which is
bounded let's say in zero one and the
laws that we
attribute to the learner is the inner
product
so that's the if you want the
expectation if you sample an expert from
these weights
of your of the loss of that expert
okay so you can think of this as doing
an expectation
in that case we're analyzing the
expected loss
you can also think of this as like
splitting maybe a euro
and actually getting this average
either way okay and the goal is again to
control the regret so we would like to
make a learner that uses these wds
and that has a loss that compares
favorably
to the loss of the best expert after
trams
[Music]
okay so what's really different what's
new what's the same
so let's see what if we can already
solve this problem with what we did
before
right so the dot loss is linear and
hence convex
great the gradient is zero unbounded
and that means that its two norm is at
most square root k
okay and the probability simplex is
contained in the unit ball
meaning that the norm of every action is
at most one
right so we can in principle apply what
we know about
online convex optimization and run
online gradient descent with d equals
one and g equals square root k
and get square with kt
good so is that the best we can do
and of course i'm asking this because
the answer is no
but it's still instructive to think why
not why
where is some slack i guess that the
lower bound has to not work
in this example and if you think what
the lower bound was doing is it was
trying to pick two points and give them
uh losses that were as different as
possible
and it was able to give them a
difference that was scaling with g
but in the simplex which is where we are
working
there are no points that have a loss
difference that is as large as square
root k
in the ball yes but in the simplex knot
so it's actually simplex is much smaller
than the ball that's one way to think
about it
and we can't we can't pos maybe we can't
get
as high as square with kt
okay and it turns out that there is an
algorithm that gets something much
better
so that's the second uh algorithm that i
think should be
in in everybody's uh toolbox
it's called exponential weights and
sometimes also the hedge algorithm
and it's designed specifically for this
simplex setting
so the way it works is
it also has a learning rate it's playing
an element of the simplex
but instead of making these gradient
steps it's doing something
else it's saying let's make the weight
at time t of expert k be proportional to
an exponentially down weighted
version of the sum of all the losses of
that expert so far
scaled by the learning rate right so
we're giving the
experts with a very large loss so far
a very small weight and the guys that
are doing the
the best they are getting the the large
weights
okay and if you like you can
think of this in an incremental version
as well
if you do that you see that the first
iterate is always uniform
and if you want to update from the
previous iterate
you multiply in one of these exponential
vectors
and we normalize okay so these are two
equivalent
ways to describe the same algorithm
okay so you can also show a regret bound
for this algorithm and uh
the outcome of the process is
in some sense similar to what happened
for online grading descent
now the regret is at most logarithm of k
over eta plus t times eta over
right you see that if you tune optimally
your eta again
you get half t times low k
all in a square root so the dependence
on t
is more or less the same as before but
now we have a logarithm of k
appearing here
okay so i want to show you the second
proof
um it's it's in some sense a
different style of proof uh
i don't know if that will be obvious to
you
uh let's let's just go over it
so if you look at urinals we can do
something that may at first look
funny which is to say let's let's
approximate
that inner product by somehow a
log some x version
so it's it's minus log
scaled by one over eta linear average
of e to the minus eta of the losses
so we would like to approximate linear
by
log sum x that is actually not an upper
bound
but if we add this extra overhead term
eta over eight
then it becomes an upper bound so this
is something known as huffing's lemma
i'll just import that at this point so
we can express
our laws as these funny things which i
think
call mixed losses and then one of these
eta over eight overheads per round
okay and then same as before we're going
to find that there is a telescoping
going on
so if you look at the sum of these mixed
losses
and you plug in the definition of the
exponential weights
uh iterate which was this
e to the minus cumulative loss
normalized
then you see that this this extra factor
for the round t
can join with all the vectors for the
previous rounds and become
a ratio of these exponentials with t
and t minus one okay so that means that
this whole thing telescopes again
to the i guess the last term
which is here and the first term where
there is nothing in the exponential so
that sums to k
which is here okay and then
you see that there is a sum
of k things if we just take instead of
the sum the minimum
because of the minus that becomes larger
and then the one overs
and the logs and the exponentials all
cancel and what remains is that we get
the
loss of the best guy okay so what we
showed is that
power loss is bounded by the loss of the
best
so the difference between that is the
regret plus
logarithm of k over eta and then
this t times eta over eight
okay so let's summarize a bit where we
are
[Music]
we saw that in in both cases we're doing
this
balancing act two terms one over a
learning rate
and a linear in the learning rate term
and you can sort of
convince yourself where these terms are
coming from
if you have if you have a large
set of candidate actions
and you make small steps because your
learning rate is small
then it takes a long time to get to a
good action
so that's what this term is about the
smaller the learning rate the larger
this is
okay and then the other term says if you
take large steps
then what's happening is you're not able
to get to a good point
but you'll constantly be flopping around
in some sense overfitting as you go and
that costs you every round
by something that scales with the
learning rate itself
well there is a question here does the
general regret result continue to hold
for convex but non-differentiable losses
if you replace the gradient by the
subgradient
the answer is yes none of this depends
on differentiability
i wrote gradient but if you do a sub
gradient
that works fine you just need
the tangent property that's overused
[Music]
okay so this this perspective on these
two bounds
it it generates a lot of questions um
you can look at all these ingredients
and wonder like
okay is this dependence what we want is
it optimal is there some other
things that we would like to have in in
place
so for example what if the horizon is
not fixed can we do something that works
at any horizon along the way what if we
don't know the gradient bound
remember it was necessary for the tuning
of the learning rate
what if we don't want a bound but the
actual gradients can we make that happen
what if we don't know the complexity of
our model so that's in this case d
uh can we adapt to uh
some good d
uh in some way so that sort of advanced
stuff uh for which i would like to refer
you to a recent icml tutorial that's
that's recorded so you can find
answers that uh to those well to that
last question in particular
for for many of these things you you
take the basic analysis that i showed
you
and you do some extra stuff so you
restart with a doubling trick you do
online decreasing
learning rates uh yielding something
like either great or ada hedge
you can learn the learning rate if you
if you
don't know that it has to always
decrease with a
scheme called metagraph so it's just
wanted to show you all these things
to point out that it's quite an active
research area
where where many interesting things are
are looked at okay
so in the rest of the time i want to do
two more things
i want to show you some advanced things
in a bit less detail
and then i want to go over a couple of
applications
so first advanced thing
is maybe the response to some question
namely
what if my domain doesn't look like a
ball
and it also doesn't look like a simplex
maybe it's some matrix domain for
example
with some norm constraints like shutter
norm
or trace norm nuclear norm there are
lots of things where
those type of actions are what you want
to think about
or it could be like a psd constraint
something so what do i do in that case
well turns out there is a generalization
of the two algorithms that i showed you
that might work for you in that case me
yeah so they are again very similar
but a little bit different sometimes uh
the first is called follow the
regularized leader
and what you do there is you say my
iterate at time t plus
1 is the point that had the best fit
on the linearized losses
in the past so up till now
but you regularize a little bit for how
extreme this u is
so you have a regularization function
convex
that penalizes use that are far away
from let's say the origin
or whatever special point in your
okay and the other scheme is called
mirror descent
where you do something similar except
you
only look at the optimization of the
loss on the last round
and you trade that off with some notion
of distance
from the previous iterate so this is i
wrote here b
it has to sort of designate a breckman
divergence
i'm not really explaining what those are
but if you have
such a bregman divergence you can run
mirror descent
okay and then if you look at what the
examples that we did so far so for
online gradient descent
the regular riser was squared euclidean
and the bregman divergence was
square duplicating distance and if you
look at exponential weights it
regularizer was a shannon entropy and
bregman divergence was
kl divergence so if you plug those in to
the above then you recover the
algorithms that we looked at already
but there are many other choices so you
can think about
borg entropy solus entropy from neumann
entropy so that that's sort of
in the all of these have matrix upgrades
von neumann is the matrix upgrade of
shin
and so there is a whole world of choices
to play with
that might give you different uh
trade-offs
that we'll discuss right next and there
are interesting connections to
something called continuous exponential
weights
which i also just want to point you to
i'm not going to say anything about them
all right so what can you show for this
ftrl or mirror descent so let me just
focus on
on one theorem it's uh for a
kind of a slightly fancy algorithm
called ada ftrl
and um but it incorporates many of the
the the sort of follow-up questions that
we were
asking before so um
let's see so we're measuring
the size of our domain u but not
directly but
with a roundabout trick we're saying
let's assume that we have a regularizer
that's both bounded
and strongly convex with respect to some
norm of our choice
right and if you have a norm you always
have an associated dual norm
okay and then add a ftrl ensures the
following
so the regret is bounded by the square
root
of the size of the
domain as given by this regularization
upper bound
times the square root of the sum of all
the gradients squared
measured in the dual norm okay so now
you get to play with these norms
fit them to your your your domain
and try to see how you optimize this
choice
okay
so let's look at the second bit
quadratic losses
uh this is actually quite important uh
to get sort of improved regret bands
if you have any special extra knowledge
so let's look at how that works so
we used complexity so at in in all the
past
to linearize we said uh at at any moment
that we have to reason
about the loss of some other point we
say that's more than the loss of the
learner plus a linear contribution
okay and we saw that all our methods
that work on these gradients are
basically
pretending that the losses were actually
this linear term
right but in many cases we may actually
know that the losses have curvature
so this linear approximation is lossy
right so what we'll look at here is how
can we represent
and quantify that curvature and how can
we
efficiently manipulate it and how much
does it help
to know about this curvature
okay so here's how we quantify
and reason about curvature we're going
to say
um let's assume that in every round
there is some matrix
that we that we know maybe after the
fact that's okay
it's a psd matrix such that the loss of
any point u is more than the linear
approximation that we saw previously
plus a quadratic term so this is a
quadratic
in u which makes this a stronger lower
bound than the complexity
lower bound okay
and let's call this whole thing the
quadratic of u
because uh we will need that next so
that's the quadratic approximation
that we use as a lower bound on the loss
of any other point
yeah maybe it's important to point out
if you plug in here wt
you see that you get wt here zero here
zero here so this quadratic is tight in
wt
and this equation this assumption says
at any other point it's a lower bound
okay so what are the important instances
of this scheme uh the first is if you
think about
uh like target shooting
uh you know telecommunications
in many cases you have to position and
you get the
square distance from some target point
maybe this is your receiver and this is
your antenna
in any case the the squared euclidean
norm satisfies this assumption with the
matrix being an identity
okay so that's very nice and simple and
more generally you can think about
strongly convex loss functions that have
this with a scaled identity
that's basically the definition okay so
that's one class
m is roughly an identity the other
important class is linear regression
and friends so linear regression
is itself a square but if you look at
the matrix that sits in there it's the
feature vector outer product it with
itself
right so that's a rank one matrix and
not a full rank matrix
and the class of x concave losses
all have a very similar feature namely
that this assumption holds for a matrix
that is rank 1
but now based on the gradient itself
right if you haven't seen x concave then
don't worry
it's some class of losses and going to
show that
i mean there linear regression is
basically the important example there
okay so
um what is the algorithm for dealing
with this quadratics we have to somehow
incorporate
this extra curvature in our in our
iterates
and the way we'll do it here is an
algorithm called online newton step
and the way i wrote it is the variant
that looks like ftrl
so the iterates that we will produce is
the minimizer of the
quadratic lower bounds and a starting
regularization which is just the square
norm
okay so what is the advantage of of
doing that
so the cool thing is is that the
computing this iterate
is just minimizing a convex quadratic
okay and if there wouldn't be the risk
the restriction that you have to play in
u
then there would be a closed form
solution we would just
invert the matrix multiplied by the
linear term
boom that's our answer if if we need to
project
um then sometimes it's closed form
sometimes there's a 1d line search
sometimes it may be more complicated but
that can also be done
okay so what do we get in the end
if your matrix is a scaled identity the
whole procedure is still
d operations per round so same as on
migrating descent
and if it's rank one then we can do some
rank one
update tricks to compute these iterates
in order d squared per round
right and in both cases there is the
projection but that's sort of an
orthogonal thing
you have to you have to deal with that
if you're unlucky that might cost you a
dq
but sometimes it's just linear it
depends a little bit on the case okay
so what can we show about online
newton's step well
the it's again different for the two
cases
if your scaled identity that's strongly
convex the regret
is only a logarithm in t so that's much
much better than a square root
and the algorithm actually looks like
online gradient descent
except with a very specific decreasing
step size
that's often how this result is
presented
but i think this is more revealing in
where it comes from
and in the x concave case where you are
are some rank one
version of the gradient then this scheme
guarantees
a regret of at most d log t
right so it's still in the log t regime
but somehow
here you're only learning about one
direction at a time so you have to pay
the
learning overhead d many times because
that's that's one way to think about it
okay so
uh what was sort of interesting and what
was happening
these convex quadratics are very nice in
that you can sum them over rounds
and represent them as sort of a single
statistic that doesn't grow in size with
the number of rounds
right so that's that's nice we can
summarize the coefficients of the sum
in a single matrix and that makes that
the runtime stays independent of the
time horizon
good we saw that curvature gives a huge
reduction in regret
goes from a square root to a logarithm
so that's great so learning is much much
easier
and you can be much more successful in
these curved regimes
and then if you're worried about run
time which i guess in some sense you
should be sometimes
sometimes the dimension is just millions
and then the square is sort of
horrible there is a very nice
way to interpolate and treat some of the
dimensions as special maintain matrix
like quantities for them
and throw away others so that's called
sketching
and this allows you to trade off both in
the runtime and in the regret
and get sort of a nice balance between
the two
all right finally i want to conclude
with
three applications so this is going to
be in some sense very fast
so first application is offline
optimization
so we've been doing things online with a
varying function a different function
every round
so what if we want to solve the
following problem
we have uh let's say gradient access to
a fixed function
and we want to find the near optimal
point
okay this is a question that maybe you
encounter at least once a day so how can
you do that with
online learning well in some sense it's
quite a natural trick
you say let's run online grading descent
and let's feed it
the same function every time okay
so if i then write down my regret bound
i see that
the sum of the losses with the same f
minus t times the loss of the best point
is bounded by
my regret bound of gd square root t
okay if i then divide by t and move the
average outside of f here inside of f
i find that i have a point namely the
average of the iterates
that looks uh that is very close in
value
to the minimizer of my f up to
something that scales as one over square
root t
okay so that means that if you want an
epsilon of optimal point
you solve for this equals epsilon and
you find that after
roughly something over epsilon squared
rounds you have
that proximity in function value
okay so now you can ask yes yes but i
can also use some other optimizer so why
would i do it this way
and i think we saw some some answer
uh like this in the previous talk
um because is this really using all that
we know
maybe if you use it maybe better that
there is a single function maybe you can
get a better
speed yeah but you can turn that around
as well
and say what if my assumptions are sort
of not quite true
if i have a robust thing like what's
written here
it might still work so for example a
thing that i encounter quite a lot is
that i have a fixed function
but i need to learn it so i have
iterates
that converge to this fixed function and
i want to optimize
with this approximate f's okay so that
this scheme can still do something for
you
if you're in a world like that
okay second application
uh what if i have stochastic data
okay so let's rephrase that in the
online convex optimization
language that means i'm going to give
myself access to a training set
so that's a bunch of functions and the
test point
and they're all drawn iid from some
unknown distribution
on loss functions in this case
okay so
what do i want i would like to look at
the training set
and output some point and i would like
this point
to do very well on a fresh test point
from the same distribution so that's
called generalization
i would like my estimate to behave like
the point that optimizes the expected
loss
okay so what can you do it's it's
somewhat similar to what we did before
you run your online learning algorithm
on the training set
so that's the functions f1 through ft
and that will give you some iterates w1
to wt
then you output the average iterate
as your candidate for this point
and you can show it's again some
manipulation with iid swapping some
things around
invoking convexity that the expected
[Music]
difference in expected loss between
your prediction and the optimal point
goes down as the regret bound divided by
t
okay so the the expected loss on the
test point uh basically if you run
online gradient descent will go down as
one over square root t
so again that gives you an idea for how
many data points you will need
to get a certain uh optimality
on on your on your general
generalization
okay last application and we also saw an
example of that which is
which is great in mandy wang's
last set so this is about
solving games and for us let's think of
very simple games
where we have some objective function
let's call it gxy that says
what is the payoff to player one
uh if player one is playing x and player
two is playing y okay so this is a
specification of the
uh of the winnings of player one and
that's
also what player 2 is losing okay
so if we have a function like that we
can think of a game
where player 1 plays x player 2 plays y
and we look at
what they what they can achieve so if
player x
goes first and y goes second
player x can achieve this
and if they change orders player y can
achieve that
and for convex concave functions there
are minimax theorems that say
these two things are the same and let's
call that quantity the value
so that's what happens if both players
play optimally
the value of the game is v star
now you can say what if they play
slightly so optimally
because we're going to try and find some
good candidates x and y so if we allow
ourselves a little epsilon
we can say that the pair of points x and
y
is an excellent saddle point if either
player by playing either x or y
and incurring the optimal response is at
most epsilon away
from v star so that's
an epsilon saddle point
and the question is how would we find an
epsilon saddle point
i'd like to compute this x bar y bar
right and the idea is well we want to
learn
so let's play a regret minimization
algorithm controlling
x and another one controlling y
and let's have them interact against
each other
updating their internal state
from what they see in each of these
interactions
okay so how does that look we do t menu
rounds
we ask each of these algorithms to play
a candidate x and a candidate y
and then we feed them as the loss
function the quality of the
other choices for x if we fix the y that
we got and for the y player we give it
the quality of all the other choices for
y if we fix the x that we got
okay and then at the very end we output
the average iterate for both of these
players
independently all right and if we assume
that these players have regret bounds
let's call that rx and ry so this would
be
what it means to be a regret bound then
the theorem is that
these iterate averages x bar and y bar
are a saddle point with quality
the regrets over t right so that could
be for example again a one over square
root t
quantity okay this is the proof but i
don't want to go into it i just want to
appreciate how short and symmetric and
elegant it is
but let's not worry all right so what
did we see
so we looked at online learning for the
full information setting
we saw that we had these powerful
results this adversarial
black box regret guarantees
and we looked at some applications
building on top of these guarantees
getting results in optimization
statistical learning
game theory solving and of course the
original interaction itself
now i just want to point at a few things
that
i left out and that i think are cool
uh so just to give you sort of a very
quick sense of what else is out there
so you may want to think what really
should control the hardness of my game
we saw for example this square root d
but is that really
what i want maybe i want to introduce
some other notion
of hardness of this of the sequential
interaction
and there are many proposals for that
first order
second order um
yeah these are all cool you can say well
if my algorithm isn't in a worst case
setting
so the there is no opponent it's
actually a distribution it's dead
maybe it should learn better or faster
if that happens
can it figure that out by itself and and
do the right thing
something called optimism which is what
if i can predict the gradient
can i learn faster the answer is yes and
it's a beautiful
theory this was the question from uh
from this court what if i don't want to
compare to a single
action what if i think that the sequence
of changing actions would be much better
so then you get into bounds for
non-stationarity tracking
or dynamic regret adaptive regret there
are all sorts of things
in this space and finally
what if i don't have a convex function
can i do something and the answer is
well there are all sorts of things
just outside you can for example zoom is
some reduced version of convexity or you
can maybe
warp everything and look at convexity in
a different space
of course we would like to understand
why these algorithms actually work for
for example deep learning and i don't
think this is explaining that yet but
it's sort of a step towards
going there okay
so thanks a lot
so there's a there's a discord question
that was sort of partly answered by your
last section on applications the
question was
in the beginning you sort of created a
hierarchy almost
of problems there's reinforcement
learning there are bandits then there
are full information problems
so the question was about could you
explain the relationship
of this tutorial like how how does it
fit in rl
uh right so one way to look at it
is if you take an rl problem
and you start stripping it down right
you you
you remove the the different states and
reduce everything down to one state
then you still have actions uh in rl you
can make these
actions but then the transition would be
back to the same state again so this is
very very
trimmed and if you also assume that uh
somehow you assume that you observe the
quality of all actions not just of the
action you pick
then you end up in the full information
setting
so that means that uh every solution to
a reinforcement learning problem has to
have some aspects of the things that i
showed you here
because it is sort of a baby instance
right so that's one answer
and the other answer i guess what i try
to illustrate with the list of
applications is that
there are many sub problems that come up
in uh
sort of the design of rl algorithms
right some of them internally as the
engine have to solve for min max
problems
and then how do you solve a min max
problem well actually that's sort of a
separate thing
for which you can make an online
learning solution to solve that
component
and then use the answer in your final
[Music]
algorithm for for a problem that lives
higher up the
up the food chain let's say all right so
it's both
special instance and tools for all the
uh
uh problems that that come up
thank you i'll add to that that tools
are very important so the expert stuff
will actually
show up again tomorrow in the morning
session in online learning part 2 where
we look at
adversarial mdps
all right i think i should hand over to
ellen now if there are any more
questions you can
i mean i'll be around i'm in the program
you can find me uh
on discord or just email
that's good thank you voter yup
enjoy the semester